[Music]
dave is in salt lake city hey dave
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um
well before i knew about you and your
program i took some loans off my 401k
and
after reading your book i i really need
to make a plan i'm a complete mess but
i'm paying like 1100 a month uh and low
to pay these loans back in my 401k and
um
obviously i took you know some advice
from people who didn't really know and
those same people have no idea how to
help me get out of this mess i'm just
curious if there's any
any way to that i can um
use
the 401k to like pay these loans off or
something to get out
from them
how much do you owe on your 401k
uh 40
thousand dollars
yes geez what'd you do with it
uh home improvement stuff paid off some
other debt just to get myself in debt
again
okay so how much debt have you got not
counting your house today
see
it'll be actually that would be 40 as
well
okay so 80 000 makes you debt free not
counting your house
correct and what do you what do you make
what's your household income
uh about 111
okay so how fast you're going to pay off
80 making 111
uh
my goal was for two years there you go
um
but i like i said i don't even so what
is the other 40
the other 40s on what
uh
there was a home equity loan and then
there was uh
some credit cards no car
uh no cars are paid for good ironically
what are they worth
uh total probably only about 15 grand
what's the boat worth an suv
what's that what's the boat worth
i don't have a boat okay just checking
it's a good test you pass the test dave
my only uh my guilty pleasure is my
writing mower and it's day 14 so okay
all right so
what we're going to do is we're going to
get on a detailed written plan
beans and rice rice and beans
you're not going on vacation until you
get this mess cleaned up you're not
going out to eat until you get this mess
cleaned up you're gonna get out the
scissors and have a plastic surgery
party tonight and chop up all your
credit cards
you gotta you gotta fix this and it's
gonna require you get radical for the
first time in your life you've been
slopping around on this subject for a
decade and you're sick of looking at
yourself in the mirror
on how it's turned out
am i right how'd you know that no
because i'm you i did it too
i know exactly how it feels
so yeah a lot of what you were saying to
other people is that with the
spiritual issue i've never really
addressed it in that hand
yeah and this is time
in your case it's time to get mad
sick and tired of being sick and tired
i'm disgusted and i'm not living like
this
any more and that's when people lose
weight and that's when they fix their
marriage and that's when they fix their
money and i'm gonna put you into
financial peace university and hook you
up with every dollar with a ramsay plus
subscription
and get you set up man and show you
exactly how to do this stuff the only
thing i ask is
by god you go do it if i give you all
this stuff for free
and then you go help somebody else when
you're rich someday and you will be if
you follow it